thank you for that introduction i'm
professor david whitcomb i am a
physician scientist
who has dedicated his career to
understanding complex traits and today
i have the privilege of talking to you
about
common risk variants and complex medical
disorders
i'd like to start with a hypothetical
case of a 33 year old woman
with five years of non-descript
abdominal pain
and she has new signs of a digestive
system inflammatory disease
on a ct scan now when she
sees this report she becomes very
worried
she begins looking on the internet and
trying to find a doctor
and she only has three questions why me
nobody in my neighborhood or my family
has ever had anything like this before
what's going to happen to me and finally
what can i do to change the outcome now
these are
very obvious and important questions for
people with a variety of complex
diseases
so she does get a chance to see one of
the world's authorities
on this disease and the doctor answers
her questions in this way
why me i don't know what's going to
happen to me
i'm not sure what can i do to change my
outcome
i don't know now they'll give some other
talk about how there's research going on
and those types of thing but the answer
is really clear
this is a failure of traditional
medicine for complex disorders
this was based on the germ theory of
disease 100 years ago
and by law all physicians have to be
taught that one factor causes
a complex syndrome and you can use
statistics
and the scientific method to calculate
what that one cause is
now we recognize that genetics is
important in medicine
but it is vastly underutilized and there
are some reasons for that
taking a genetic approach there is a
problem called
missing hereditability in which there
are some
genetic mutations that are called
pathogenic that
cause a rare mendelian disorder however
when the genome was completely
sequenced and we began to find that
there were other associations there were
genetic risk factors
that were found that were associated
with a disease
but they were actually relatively common
and
they didn't actually cause a disease
they just were associated with it
so what causes these diseases and that
was called the missing hereditability
we addressed this in a paper shown at
the bottom of your slide
and what we argue is that the missing
hereditability
is actually two genes at once that are
coming together
or a state occurs in which a very
important
mutation is silent but suddenly becomes
important
and drives disease
now what we've learned is that most
genetic information
is useless in western medicine
and that's why it's not been adopted we
understand pathogenic variants and
that's
the disease genes that will cause things
like cystic fibrosis
or other major disorders in which
there's autosomal dominant or recessive
inheritance however there's a variety of
risk factors that we're not sure what to
do with
they're found in g was studies they're
common they're in non-coding parts of
the gene
they're not necessary or sufficient to
cause the disease
and they may be linked to other things
like alcohol use smoking
or other types of risk factors
we also recognize but are not sure what
to do with the fact that they can be
part of complex
gene gene interactions or gene
environment interactions
they may be similar or different to what
we would call a modifier gene
and they're not disease specific they're
seen in several diseases
but not others now the reason that we're
having a problem
is that we're taught as physicians to
use
the gold standard which is the
randomized controlled trial
for a complex chronic disease and what's
shown at the top
is a disease that has been pulled out of
a general population to make a
population
of patients with a disease and what you
see is it follows sort of a gaussian
where on the left there are patients
that have very mild disease and on the
right there are people with very severe
disease
in the middle our patients sort of have
average disease
and those are the ones that are
considered to be most homogeneous
and so there are inclusion exclusion
criteria
to study this disease of course the ones
that are suffering the most
actually never get studied in these
clinical trials
what we find is that very few patients
actually respond
to a medication and so very large
international studies are done
in order to show that there's any
efficacy at all
most medicines that we use have a number
needed to treat of four or five
and sometimes more meaning that if you
have five
patients only one of them will respond
to the medication
why is that well what we propose is that
the etiologies are different even though
the symptoms are the same
so the same organ becomes inflamed but
there's a variety of different reasons
or combinations of reasons
and if we use a very narrow inclusion
exclusion
criteria we may get a lot of patients
with mild disease that
aren't going to really make that much
difference and we exclude people
with a more severe disease even though
there may be a very
obvious target that could help that
subset of patients
that has that disease and so the effect
of combining everybody by symptom
rather than separating them by actual
disease mechanism
is the limitation between germ theory
disease
and precision medicine
now precision medicine is a new paradigm
in contrast to the old paradigm
which is the germ theory of disease one
factor causes everything
and i'd like to use the example of
chronic pancreatitis and what we'll do
is we'll go from the old germ theory of
disease to the new
precision medicine which really requires
a lot of computational
biology and other factors hereditary
pancreatitis is a form of pancreatitis
that does run in the family
this is a cat scan in the middle is a
diseased pancreas
and all the complications of
pancreatitis
which is inflammation of the pancreas
are shown here
now the gene that causes this is shown
in the upper right this is the trypsin
gene or prss1
in purple and the inhibitor spank1
is shown in red people with this
mutation which is the worst mutation we
know
have an 80 chance of having an episode
of acute pancreatitis
sometime in their life in addition
those who have acute pancreatitis about
half of them
progress to chronic pancreatitis which
is complete scarring of the pancreas
the other half don't seem to progress
those that get pancreatic chronic
pancreatitis
about 40 of them develop pancreatic
cancer
later in life and so we see there's a
progression
of disease of the organ even though
there's only one gene
that seems to trigger the whole process
to split this up and to understand that
we developed a disease model and the
disease model
helps us understand why the symptoms
occur at different periods of time um
and in different concentrations so for
example in diabetes
only about 40 percent develop diabetes
and the others don't
why is that what we see
is that if we look at a progressive
model of chronic pancreatitis
we start at the left at people that are
at risk because they'll go for 10 15
20 years with no symptoms then suddenly
something will trigger
an attack of acute pancreatitis where
the pancreas becomes inflamed
that's called the sentinel acute
pancreatitis event or
s state and you end up with
what looks like early chronic
pancreatitis with a lot of inflammation
but in most cases it resolves some
people
start having recurrent episodes over and
over again
a subset of patients progress to
established and then stage chronic
pancreatitis
because there's variable effects on the
immune system
or on the aston cells that make
digestive enzymes
or on the island cells that make insulin
or on
the nerves that cause pain or on the dna
repair system
that leads to cancer these are
completely different cells
there's different risk factors in each
cell and there's different
things that drive injury or repair
in each of the different cell types so
of course they don't go in parallel
but by organizing in this way we can
put the genetic factors into a
injury inflammation resolution
regeneration sequence
that in some cases goes terribly long
wrong
leading to recurrent acute pancreatitis
or chronic pancreatitis
in addition it allows for the
consideration of multiple risk factors
some are genetic some are metabolic some
are environmental
we've organized these into a system
called tiger o
which is an acronym i'll talk about on
the next slide
what we see is the features of the end
stage
disease are not surrogates of each other
they're
caused by different cell types and if
you take a cat scan
and see how much fibrosis in the
pancreas you cannot predict
whether or not they have digestive
insufficiency
whether or not they have diabetes
whether or not they have pain or whether
or not they're developing cancer
because each of them have a different
combination of factors
and so we have to actually look at each
one of those
individually also if you try to treat
patients at this stage
it's too late the patient's pancreas is
already destroyed
we have to find early signs and symptoms
and identify those patients
that are progressing because of a
specific mechanism
in doing that we begin to understand
that the
diagnosis has to be early so that the
therapy can be aimed at the patients at
the beginning of the disease
not after it's too late
now here are the different causes of
pancreatitis and there's a whole list of
them
there are toxic metabolic factors like
too much alcohol and smoking
idiopathic used to be a big
classification and now it's small
genetics is becoming more important
autoimmune is rare recurrent and severe
acute pancreatitis is usually caused by
gallstone
and obstructive is where there are
factors outside the pancreas that are
obstructing
the gut and causing problems so what
we're beginning to learn is the toxic
and the genetic factors are important so
let's look at some of the genetic
factors
there's dozens of them and they're in
different mechanisms some are autosomal
dominant
some are recessive some are modifier
genes
others are risk factors and some work
inside the pancreas and outside the
pancreas
so we really have to understand exactly
how to organize before
we can determine what to do with it now
what we recognize
is that on the far left the clinician
evaluates the patients
and now they're trying to guess what's
going to happen in the outcome
there's a variety of things recurrent
acute pancreatitis exocrine
pancreatic insufficiency where no
digestion occurs
atrophy of the pancreas and other things
so at ariel we begin to look at what are
the hidden mechanisms
and the way we did that we said okay
what we know
is that there are ideologic factors that
drive
injury the cells or the asana cells that
make the digestive enzymes
and we know that there's a number of
digestive enzymes
that when mutated increase the risk of
disease
there's also the duct cell these are
important for squirting the enzymes
out of the pancreatic gland and into the
intestine and we're familiar with the
cystic fibrosis gene cftr
and that is the dominant gene in the
duct cell but there are other ones that
are important as well
there's also external factors we have to
think about is there obstruction
is there autoimmunity has there been
trauma
any of these things can be mild or
severe
but amazingly the pancreas can adapt
to it and prevent severe
problems from occurring however we also
see that there are specific
responses that occur with different
types of injury
and i've listed the type of injury
responses in the genes
that are known to protect the pancreas
but if there's mutations
in the response gene the injury response
fails and damage occurs and we know that
occurs in different cells
with different types of outcomes so we
can actually link those things together
so how do we begin thinking about this
and determining what
actually is linking together
the aerial scientist studied 100
patients
in which the etiology was unknown and
could not be
described we picked 10 factors
10 genes that were most known to be
associated
and looked at all of the variants that
kept popping up
in deep sequencing and what we found was
there was a number of pathogenic
variants that were overexpressed
compared to what we would see in
based on the minor allele frequency and
then we look to see
if they were occurring together in any
particular type of pattern
what we found is that there was a
connection
between different types of genetic
variants
and they had a general pattern
where there was uh injury generation
injury response which normally
compensates for the injury
but if you have a combination of extra
injury and failed response you get
a disease how we looked at this is
by mapping out all the genetic variants
and you'll see at the top is the afner
cells
and on the left the duct cells where the
generate
the injury is generated and on the right
you see the defense mechanisms
injury or impair and at the bottom a
gene that is a
ubiquitous ligase that cleans up
secretory proteins and other proteins
that are misfolded or
in the wrong part of the cell they're in
the cytoplasm or in the nucleus where
they should be
in a secretory pathway and what we see
is
that there is a tight link between genes
that are in a secretory pathway
and we know are misfolded or don't work
properly
in the uh the proteins
uh clearance clearance medicine
mechanism
and so those two tend to be linked
together
in addition we see that the duct cell
if there are different types of cftr
variants that are not pathogenic
they seem to cluster with a important
gene called ggt1
which is an antioxidant that occurs in
the duct cells
that protects the pancreas and the duct
cells from
injury and it also is linked with the
ubr1
so that if you have a combination of
these factors
the cells fail and you end up developing
chronic pancreatitis
so now we're beginning to understand how
these things work together
so let's consider the polygenic risk
score
how do you put multiple snips together
to empower
precision medicine well there's a lot of
problems with this
and it has been very difficult for it to
gain traction
part of the reason is that these
variants are
found by association studies where you
take all the cases and all the controls
not looking at mechanisms but at disease
symptoms
and it could even include things like
icd-10 codes or other things in order
to classify these patients even though
they internally are very different
these are common variants with low to
moderate effect size
so they're not disease-causing by
themselves
these variants are used
to make a polygenic risk score which
i'll talk about
on the next slide there's a number of
challenges because
they're distinct from the tag snips
these are used as proxies
for a whole variety of snips in a
certain location
for identifying genetic risk and the tag
snips are often part of very large
haplotypes
which have multiple functional variants
and so it can become difficult
to understand exactly what each variant
does
and how to entangle these things there's
also major penalties for
multiple testing of huge numbers of
snips false discovery
there are lack of a deep coverage of
certain genes because
the uncommon variants are not there the
structural variants are often under
represented the effect size of
the variants are also hard to calculate
because it depends on the
comparison group it depends on the
ancestry of the patient being evaluated
and the types of cases that can be
accessed and other selection bias
and so these effect sizes are highly
relevant to the context also comparison
between clinical studies is very
difficult
as people will use different snip arrays
and other
features where we've tried to use
imputation but there's many many
limitations and the other big problem is
phenotyping
it's incomplete it's inaccurate and
imprecise
and so these case control studies have
some inherent
problems the polygenic risk scores also
have problems in themselves
it is a list of variants associated with
the disease
but the score is based on the sum of the
variance it doesn't really give you
a lot of insight these are
adjusted by statistical odd ratios or
the log of the odds ratios
to sort of weight these a little bit to
help improve
the uh the accuracy they've been shown
to be quite useful for populations
but they're less useful for individuals
and for precision medicine
it's the individual we're trying to
understand so
there's an overlap of the cases of
controls
based on a polygenic risk score again
these scores look at the relative risk
rather than absolute risk
and they really don't understand the
complex relationship
between snips that our scientists at
ariel
are teasing out as i showed on one of
the previous slides
it does not provide significant insight
and disease mechanism
it's just an association and it doesn't
guide you toward
the appropriate therapy
i'm going to show you an example that we
have used from my university of
pittsburgh study on the pancreatic titus
group
and the question was why do some people
get diabetes
and others don't and the thought was
well maybe they have
type 2 genetic mutations that are giving
them
the disease so what we did is we took
people
with pancreatitis but without diabetes
and
patients with chronic pancreatitis and
diabetes
calculated their polygenic risk score
and in the middle
we looked at the polygenic risk score of
a comparison population
that only had type 2 diabetes without
pancreatitis
and what we found was the patients
that were with chronic pancreatitis and
no diabetes were highly different
than those with type 2 diabetes but the
patient
with chronic pancreatitis and diabetes
had risk scores that were almost
identical to people with type 2 diabetes
without chronic pancreatitis so this
clearly shows
that if you have type 2 diabetes risk
and pancreatitis you're likely to get
diabetes
however how do you apply this to an
individual patient
what you see when you look at these
contour plots
is that that on a population basis
there's a big difference between the
weighted scores of patients with and
without diabetes
but an individual patient with a score
of 70
you have no idea if they're going to get
diabetes or not there's such a huge
overlap that it's very difficult to
apply this
to an individual patient now at ariel
we're very excited about using snip
panels
what we've done is that we have tried to
focus
on the specialized cells and the biology
of the
organs in the systems associated with
the signs and symptoms of disease
we link the physicians questions which
are very specific
with actionable data and clinical
decision support
the genotyping that we use depends on
how much you want to spend we can
do whole genome sequencing while exome
sequencing
a custom sequence panel which we're very
excited about
because it provides a lot of
opportunities for difficult to
evaluate regions and then a modified
snip chip
which has incredible potential for
screening for these disease and
classifying patients
and it has a low affordable cost
so there's an integration of the effects
of
each gene and summarized
and quantified and they're linked to the
cells in which is expressed
the mechanistic role within the cell and
how it interplays with biology and
pathogenesis
modeling is then used to combine the
genetic altering mechanisms the
environment and other knowledges
we bring biomarkers in to determine how
active the disease is
and how far progressed it is and the
information is backed into models
that then tell what is going to happen
under the circumstances that's unique to
that specific patient
expert systems are needed to take the
knowledge of biology and medicine and
put them together to classify a patient
it's used to predict the biomarkers that
are needed to
to determine exactly what's wrong or
other specialized tests
and to understand the treatment options
that
are necessary to come up with the best
management plan
there's a number of limitations though
using a snip chip
one of them is that there's only a
subset of possible genetic variant
variants that can be used there are many
that have not been discovered yet
or not included the model is not
therefore 100
accurate it can just guide on
subpopulations
of patients with a similar signs and
symptoms
and what is the likelihood they have one
disease versus another
and it does prevent an opportunity
though
to use polygenic risk scores with
a lot of additional information as a
clinical support tool
not only for pancreatitis but for a
variety of other complex chronic
diseases such as diabetes
hyperlipidemia liver diseases uh
digestive problems we're studying on and
even covid19
which we are helping to understand as
well
so how does what we're doing in ariel
differ than
a classic genetic report well if a
physician sees a patient says they
i think they might have cystic fibrosis
they'll look at the signs and symptoms
they'll look at the risk factors such as
family history their ancestry
and germline genetics looking for
pathogenic disease-causing genes
and then they write a report but that's
only about
three to five percent of the patients
with the same signs and symptoms
what's really needed is to expand the
genetic report
and to transform it into a clinical
decision support
so that the physician knows that every
patient what's wrong and what to do
about it
in order to do that there's additional
acquired risk that are important to
understand
in addition to that the mendelian
and the complex genetics have to be
considered
so that there's additional risk factors
that are reported
then the patient state has to be brought
in how old are they what's their sex
what are their comorbidities
what other factors they have what
biomarkers are there of disease is it
active or not
are there imaging findings what
laboratories are abnormal
is there pathology that information is
put into a expert system
that helps discern the mechanism of the
disease
what kind of additional test will make
the correct diagnosis
of the disorder rather than the end
stage disease
how far along is the patient in the
disease progression
how much activity is there what is the
trajectory what are the other
comorbidities that are likely to occur
and what kind of a treatment can you use
and are the risk or benefits of using
one treatment or the other
those pieces of information then provide
clinical decision support
with a follow-up to understand patients
that do or do not respond
to the recommended treatment and to
continually learn
a better way to provide precision
information
to each and every patient there's a 10
things that have been proposed that have
to be done
in order to achieve precision medicine
these have been listed
and published a number of years ago with
the beginning
of the precision medicine
interest and all of these have to be
brought together in some way
at ariel what we recognize is both the
physician
and the patient has the key tools in
order to do precision medicine
and that's a smart phone where an
e-prescription can be sent to a patient
they can be contacted at their home all
the
exchange can be done by the phone by
internet and by mail
and a complete report that actually
provides direction for the physician
can come back to them as well thank you
for your attention
if there's any questions i'm happy to
explain them to you
and help you understand that aerial
precision medicine
is actually both a research and a
clinical genomics
health information technology company so
that patients
in research studies can have clinical
genetic
test results to come back so they can be
properly classified
and followed for future understanding of
disease
thank you